on va recevoir sur ce plateau dans un
court instant des experts politologues
sondeurs spécialiste en communication
mais d'abord ce qu'il faut retenir des
annonces présidentielles avec Hugo
Lemonnier
après trois mois d'une mobilisation
historique contre la réforme des
retraites le président de la République
a choisi de s'adresser aux Français dans
une allocution sans contradiction avec
un premier message la réforme des
retraites était nécessaire en effet
alors que le nombre de retraités
augmente que notre espérance de vie
s'allonge la réponse ne pouvait pas être
de baisser les pensions elle ne pouvait
pas être non plus d'augmenter les
cotisations de ceux qui travaillent et
ne pouvait pas être comme je l'ai
beaucoup entendu de ne rien faire car
c'était alors laissé les déficits
s'accumuler et notre dette augmentée
pour les générations futures faute
d'abandonner le report de l'âge légal à
64 ans Emmanuel Macron fait un constat
le gouvernement n'a pas su convaincre
cette réforme est-elle acceptée
à l'évidence non et malgré les mois de
concertation un consensus n'a pas pu
être trouvé et je le regrette
nous devons en tirer tous les
enseignements vivement critiqués par les
organisations syndicales depuis la
promulgation de la réforme quelques
heures seulement après la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel le président
appelle maintenant à une reprise du
dialogue social
et cela afin d'ouvrir sans aucune limite
sans aucun tabou une série de
négociations sur des sujets essentiels
améliorer les revenus des salariés
faire progresser les carrières
mieux partager la richesse améliorer les
conditions de travail trouver des
solutions à l'usure professionnelle
accroître l'emploi des seniors et aider
aux reconversions le chef de l'État
adresse par ailleurs une liste de trois
grands chantiers d'abord le travail puis
la justice l'immigration la réforme des
institutions
le progrès je veux que chacun d'entre
vous retrouve la certitude que nos
enfants pourront bâtir une vie meilleure
et ce sont nos services publics qui
devront porter cette espérance de la
petite enfance au grand âge un nouveau
discours de la méthode plutôt qu'un
programme et enfin un calendrier le
président se donne 100 jours et fixe un
rendez-vous avec les Français le 14
juillet pour dresser un premier bilan de
son action
allez je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de ce second débat Florent radio
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes président du
sing tank du cercle de réflexion l'été
riz et enseignant à Sciences Po
pyradrien Bartoli bonsoir bienvenue à
vous directeur des études politiques
chez Harris interactif Pascal Perino
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue Pascal vous
êtes politologue et professeur à
Sciences Po et vous attendez un stylo
donc je passe le message en régie si on
pouvait trouver un stylo pour Pascal
Perino ce serait vraiment sympa Émilie
Émilie appelle ski spécialiste en
communication politique est resté à mes
côtés merci Émilie peut-être
une première intervention on a beaucoup
parlé du fond avec nos invités
politiques dans la première partie de
cette édition spéciale peut-être sur la
forme euh je commence avec vous Florent
vas-y ok qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé
dans le ton du président de la
République ce soir par rapport à sa
précédente intervention par exemple j'ai
trouvé que le Président de la République
était beaucoup plus dans un ton maîtrisé
dans un ton beaucoup plus neutre j'avais
eu l'occasion de dire sur votre plateau
que la précédente intervention était à
mes yeux un peu orgueilleuse ça n'était
pas le cas ce soir on retrouvait
finalement le Emmanuel Macron donc on
est toujours en train de chercher quel
Emmanuel Macron quelle saison on a perdu
en quelque sorte mais il était
finalement dans un temps assez maîtrisé
assez serein présidentiel en réalité
c'est l'exercice qui le requierait parce
que il n'avait pas d'aller dans la
locution sur la neige dans un cadre
assez connu avec finalement un
séquencement de la vie politique qui
était assez classique c'est-à-dire une
crise politique
durable donc une allocution
présidentielle courte il faut le noter
très courte même la 13 minutes 30 oui
mais la chute était presque surprenante
heureusement qu'il y a la Marseillaise
parfois et donc c'est finalement un
élément assez classique qui me fait
penser à ce que Brigitte ghaïti appelle
la sortie charismatique de crise
c'est-à-dire que le Président de la
République il a des connaissances mais
visiblement il y a pas assez d'histoires
c'est à dire que à chaque fois qu'il est
une crise ben le président de la
République fait une sortie pour essayer
de temporiser de calmer là le président
de la République a fait une sortie je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il est ni temporisé ni
calmé ni offert des perspectives Pascal
perrineo il y a eu plusieurs temps dans
le depuis six ans maintenant qu'il est
au pouvoir heureusement et des occasions
quand même Emmanuel Macron dans la forme
a su réinventer un peu le discours
présidentiel là c'était pas le cas mais
c'était pas les c'était pas le cadre non
plus on était dans la locution sur la
neige en tête quoi c'était pas le cas de
c'était pas le moment non plus les
Français en effet comme il répétait je
ne sais combien de reprise sont en
colère et il s'agissait pas de tenter
d'innover dans la forme il fallait faire
dans le classique et là il a fait dans
le classique à la fois dans le ton dans
le lieu
dans le contenu du message
pour vous même en creux non en creux oui
entre les lignes on peut lire mais à
coule pas quand il dit au fond voilà
c'est très fort mais non accepté
j'allais dire oui il a accepté il est
peut-être pour quelque chose voilà mais
voilà il faut vraiment lire entre les
lignes mais il y a pas eu de mea culpa
affiché il manquait un tout petit peu
dans l'intervention présidentielle
j'allais dire d'affect les Français
réagissent dans la rue avec beaucoup
d'affaires il y a beaucoup de passions
parfois de passion triste parfois de
passion moins triste et le président de
la République en effet reste en effet
vous le disiez d'un calme d'une sérénité
absolue alors que tout de même ça
énormément tangué et on ne sentait pas
si vous voulez que le président en haut
du système a pris conscience de
l'ampleur du tangage que la France a
traversé et devenu peut-être à traverser
on verra ça le 1er mai la deuxième
élément aussi il n'y a pas de nouveautés
pas de nouveautés dans la forme mais pas
de nouveauté aussi au fond tous les
grands dossiers qu'il annonce sont des
dossiers qui sont déjà en cours alors ça
on y reviendra un peu plus tard si vous
voulez le côté voilà bref mais bref
aussi dans l'évaluation quand il dit
voilà le 14 juillet on fait dans son
jour on fait le bilan je veux dire
attention d'ailleurs dans l'histoire de
France les 100 jours vous voyez c'est
napoléonien mais ça lui a pas finalement
de l'oublions jamais comment vous
analysez l'intervention présidentielle
pierre Adrien Bartoli par rapport à
aussi le qu'il cherchait à toucher parce
que c'est aussi ce qu'on vient chercher
dans votre expertise évidemment je pense
qu'on comprend bien la locution quand on
réfléchit au cible et notamment à aux
personnes à qui parler en premier
c'est-à-dire c'est sympathisant pour les
agrégés autour de lui et éventuellement
cette deuxième cible c'est sympathisant
des républicains qui sont pas si
éloignés de lui et dont il va avoir
besoin vu que son aile gauche disons ces
gens de centre gauche qui l'oubliez
plutôt d'un bon œil au début du mandat
commence un petit peu à l'abandonner
là-dessus c'est plutôt bien réussi
c'est-à-dire qu'il prend un ton neutre
il reste dans le cadre assez classique
de l'intervention présidentielle et
surtout à aucun moment ni sur le fond on
y reviendra ni sur la forme il cherche à
convaincre parce que quand il cherche à
convaincre il Clive la base de la
discussion
à portée de baffes presque président de
la République qui l'aime on le sait et
qui était pas du tout le format une
interview c'est une allocution et qui
était surtout quelque chose qui parfois
le dessert parce que l'emmène dans ses
travers donc on a vu un président assez
calme assez neutre assez en retenue sans
affect ce que disait parce qu'elle fait
qu'il y a pas d'affect et donc pas
vraiment d'empathie vis-à-vis des
Français et ça c'est un problème parce
que on aurait pu s'attendre un président
qui allait dire après toute la séquence
on est en désaccord sur le fond on est
d'accord mais je vous ai compris et en
fait toute la séquence et toute la
locution visent plutôt à dire vous ne
m'avez pas compris ce qui à mon avis est
compliqué pour recréer du lien
effectivement le mode confiance ça va
être un mot très important dans les dans
les prochains jours et dans les
prochaines semaines notamment dans sa
dans sa façon de convaincre les
syndicats à revenir autour d'une table
de négociation c'est vraiment l'enjeu ce
sera pas avant le 1er dans la bien
compris de toute façon mais après ça va
être quand même très compliqué ça peut
être intéressant Emily de comparer on a
commencé à le faire là mais vraiment
cette intervention avec l'interview
télévisée du 22 mars dans les dans les
trésors de TF1 et France 2 on est dans
deux formes différentes mais c'est
vraiment intéressant de les comprendre
l'horaire était différente beaucoup plus
solennel c'est vrai beaucoup plus
classique mais c'est vrai qu'on a eu un
Emmanuel Macron parmi des multiples
facettes beaucoup moins provocateur on a
eu quelqu'un quand même de beaucoup plus
ouvert il y a eu le jeu il y a eu le
nous il y a eu beaucoup de mots sur les
un mea culpa je pense quand même en
creux quand il l'a dit il n'y a pas eu
d'accepte pas eu d'acceptation de la
réforme pas de consensus il faudra en
tirer les enseignements mais on sait pas
très bien ce que ça veut dire derrière
il reconnaît aussi la colère et pas du
tout de la même façon que le 22 mars à
13h puisqu'il avait parlé des factieux
des factions là il dit ce sont des
manifestations pour l'immense majorité
qui sont tenus dans le calme et même il
ajoute dans le respect des institutions
alors personne n'est surtout pas moi ne
peut rester sourd voilà mais l'anticipe
les critiques de des oppositions sur le
thème il reste sur toi que je reconnais
la colère mais je ne sais pas quels
enseignements on peut en tirer donc il
reste assez nébuleux là-dessus on le
voit aussi ben on l'a dit entre
l'urgence et l'apaisement c'est-à-dire à
la fois je prends acte de cette non
acceptation mais je vais vite au
chantier et puis je m'évite la date du
14 juillet fête nationale en parlant de
l'indépendance nationale il a dit il a
parlé beaucoup de ça et il est revenu
enfin sur cette fameuse date des 100
jours moi j'ai l'impression qu'il a pas
forcément la même façon de de
communiquer son émotion ou en tout cas
de ressentir les choses parce que j'ai
senti des séquences émotions qui m'ont
fait penser aux vœux aussi alors il y a
pas que quand il a parlé d'autres dames
il a dit jour pour jour c'est le moment
où Notre-Dame et je vous promettais que
j'allais rebâtir enfin je vous je disais
qu'on allait rebâtir notre Dame c'était
un peu la séquence l'arme à l'oeil et je
pense que pour lui ça veut dire beaucoup
et pour nous peut-être un peu moins donc
c'était cette idée de refaire cet élan
les bâtisseurs il avait parlé pendant
ses vœux de la génération de bâtisseurs
que nous étions les Français et les
Français je pense que quand les
bâtisseurs sont plutôt en train de
compter leurs sous c'est pas tout à fait
les mêmes soucis et ça fait pas écho aux
mêmes émotions je pense il a dit aussi
je nous fais confiance il y a eu
beaucoup un ces mots on l'a dit
d'associer de mieux associer les corps
intermédiaires mais toujours pas la
méthode toujours pas les preuves d'amour
que on aurait pu imaginer là-dedans de
solliciter les forces que ça soit par
des coalitions ou des alliances donc on
a senti cette ma rendu mais
malheureusement on voit pas tellement de
gens en face de cette main tendue
beaucoup plus de calme un élan l'envie
de faire un élan à la fin il a terminé
je pense que c'était d'ailleurs à propos
de Notre-Dame sur l'élan provoqué et que
l'élan et les trois chantiers qui
devaient nous rassembler voilà donc
c'était beaucoup de beaucoup plus de
calme en tout cas que le 22 mars à 13h
mais un président peut-être pas assez
concret sur les préoccupations du
quotidien beaucoup de promesses mais pas
forcément de preuve réelle merci Émilie
pour ce résumé sur la forme alors il y a
évidemment ce qui nous a tous frappé les
100 jours on l'a déjà évoqué mais on va
pouvoir en débattre un peu plus
longuement y conclut en disant son jour
d'apaisement d'unité d'ambition et
d'action et écouter le moment où il
donne finalement dans cette feuille de
route aussi un calendrier les 100 jours
le 14 juillet prochain doit nous
permettre de faire un premier bilan nous
avons devant nous 100 jours
d'apaisement d'unités
d'ambition et d'action au service de la
France c'est notre devoir et je vous
fais confiance je nous fais confiance
pour y arriver
Florent Vaillot c'est c'est
effectivement l'a dit dans notre premier
débat politique mais c'est en général un
discours qu'on entend chez un nouveau
président fraîchement élu qui se dit
j'ai 100 jours pour faire les grandes
réformes allons-y c'est alors évidemment
Emmanuel Macron quand il choisit ses
cette expression et il sait qu'on a tous
cette référence en tête lui aussi il l'a
en tête qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour
vous parce que depuis une semaine on on
a montré les tiraillements qui pouvaient
y avoir au sein de l'exécutif enfin
entre le apaiser de d'Elizabeth borne et
le accélérer d'Emmanuel Macron moi je
100 jours j'entends accélérer forcément
et vous moi j'entends trois messages
convergent le premier c'est que c'est
presque l'espérance de vie d'Elizabeth
borne parce que le premier bilan ça sera
aussi celui d'Elisabeth borne pour
l'instant c'est un échec depuis le cap
fixé le 22 mars elle devait élargir elle
devait apaiser elle devait convaincre
mais là j'ai la musique de Mission
Impossible qui qui
je pense qu'elle l'avait elle aussi
cette musique donc il y a ces premiers
100 jours le deuxième élément c'est que
à force de toujours prendre un
calendrier une scénarisation de la vie
politique en fait on est dans une
scénarisation de la vie politique ça
montre que on ne maîtrise pas le temps
politique parce que le Président de la
République essaie de reprendre la main
sur un agenda politique dont il a perdu
l'initiative parce que désormais ce sont
les manifestations qui rythme cet agenda
politique les prises de parole de
Laurent Berger donc on est vraiment sur
une dynamique ou la majorité n'a plus la
main et le troisième élément c'est à mon
sens qu'il connaît parfaitement le
calendrier évidemment parlementaire qui
est le sien et c'est 100 premiers jours
en réalité il n'y aura de travail ni sur
la question du travail précisément
puisqu'elle vient plus tard en juillet
il n'y aura pas sur la rénovation
écologique puisque une partie des
annonces a déjà été faites on voit pas
ce que la première ministre va annoncer
en revanche au Parlement il y a une loi
très importante qui est la loi de
programmation militaire
et donc avec les 413 milliards d'euros
dont la plupart est après 2027 mais
c'est néanmoins un effet d'annonce le
président de la République va jouer
l'indépendance nationale terme qui est
revenu très souvent presque étonnamment
souvent l'indépendance nationale les
sujets consensuels parce que va-t-on se
déchirer sur les questions militaires et
puis le président de la République qui
préside donc finalement il a annoncé un
calendrier une scénarisation dans
laquelle il maîtrise tout de même
quelques-uns des ressorts principaux
pour sa narration alors il y a deux
aspects sur lequel je veux bien qu'on
rebondisse c'est effectivement la
question du maître des horloges et puis
je reprends le tout début de votre
intervention sur finalement l'avenir
d'Elizabeth borne Pascal perrineo il n'y
a pas eu beaucoup de mots
gentils pour Isabelle ni le 22 mars ni
ce soir non non il a beauté pour la prêt
en disant voilà ça manque peut-être un
peu de concret si on lisait entre les
lignes mais pour le concret vous verrez
avec madame la Première ministre feuille
de route la feuille de route la semaine
prochaine donc Madame Elizabeth borne va
se mettre au travail pour mettre en
musique la partition présidentielle mais
là on est dans la répartition des rôles
relativement classiques sous la
profiter de cette allocution pour
marquer un soutien plus fort pour
marquer un soutien et là on est bien
dans un Emmanuel Macron qui a beaucoup
de mal à accorder de la place à la
fonction primo ministérielle c'était
déjà le cas pour les deux premiers
ministres précédents mais c'était déjà
le cas pour les deux présidents
précédents aussi
certainement et les tempéraments aussi
peut-être mais là j'allais dire c'est
peut-être porté avec Emmanuel Macron à
son point d'orgue on se disait tiens
l'hyper Président c'est Nicolas Sarkozy
qui l'a inventé mais quelque part c'est
peut-être Emmanuel Macron qui est en
train de la réaliser parce que tout de
même
dans ce dans cette courte intervention
j'allais dire il commence j'allais dire
en assumant totalement le scénario qui
s'est passé il nous dit voilà la loi sur
les retraites a été votée elle est
conforme à la Constitution
elle est marquée par certes elle vous
demande un effort mais les marquée par
la justice et troisièmement elle était
nécessaire et puis ensuite une fois que
ça a été bien cadré bon maintenant
parlons parlons de la suite vous allez
être un peu plus raisonnable vous allez
peut-être revenir et je vais vous donner
quelques bonnes raisons de revenir à la
table des négociations donc c'est tout
même un homme qui reste droit dans ses
bottes pour reprendre une très vieille
expression et là ça manque peut-être
j'allais presque d'une habilité parce
que on peut dire voilà maintenant ça y
est les choses sont faites ça c'est déjà
de dire toujours passer comme ça dans la
réforme des retraites la loi est votée
dans une atmosphère où personne n'est ou
bien le parfois ça se passe par la voie
réglementaire aussi et personne n'est
d'accord et puis après on reprend le
cours des choses mais mais là étant
donné l'intensité de l'opposition qu'il
a reconnu c'est une réforme non acceptée
là les termes sont lourds parce que
c'est très fort mais elle a été toi-même
acceptée voilà oui il y avait une
diabète quand même un tiers des Français
qui qui qui
sont électorat à lui oui mais par
rapport à Perrineau par rapport au
précédentes réforme des retraite qui
certes était un populaire là il y a la
dimension de la méthode
gouvernementale et parlementaire qui qui
rajoute c'est presque ça rajoute alors
moi je sais pas s'il faut employer le
terme crise démocratique mais en tout
cas questionnement sur le fonctionnement
de démocratie et sur l'exercice du
pouvoir donc c'est c'est un cran
supplémentaire je trouve supplémentaire
parce que ça s'est passé dans un
contexte de brutalisation assez intense
les instruments utilisés alors chaque
instrument en tant que tel ça pose pas
de problème mais le cumulation le cumul
des instruments du parlementarisme
rationalisé utilisé dans une certaine
fièvre ça crée un certain climbré mais
le Conseil constitutionnel a dit c'est
bon
voilà et c'est là où il se permet de
juger un peu l'opportunité de la réforme
mais on sait que le Conseil
constitutionnel voilà il juge le droit
et juridiquement en effet voilà il a
constaté qu'il n'y avait pas ce point de
détail qui n'avait pas de problème
majeurs mais là on est au cœur de ce qui
se passe depuis un an parce que au fond
c'est une situation radicalement
nouvelle gouvernée avec un déficit de de
40 à 45 c'est une situation tout à fait
nouvelle comment vous faites pour
gouverner ou bien vous passez un accord
c'est ce qu'on le bruit qu'on entend
aujourd'hui vous passez un accord avec
une force qui est une force d'opposition
c'est le fameux y aura-t-il un jour ou
non un accord avec les LR combien de LR
etc ou bien vous faites ça et vous
arrivez à gouverner j'allais dire
relativement pas pacifiquement ou bien
vous brutalisez à la fois les
oppositions et votre majorité et c'est
ce qui s'est passé et je ne vois pas
très bien une troisième solution alors
justement je viens vers vous pierre
Adrien Bartoli parce que dans les
options et que vous avez testé
évidemment auprès de l'opinion publique
il y a le l'option des solutions
l'option remaniement et je reviens à la
au destin d'isabet de bord l'option le
changement de Premier ministre qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui domine d'une certaine
façon dans les souhaits des Français
elle a dissolution mais ça Emmanuel
Macron va pas y aller on a bien compris
mais c'est un peu le problème c'est que
toutes les options sont un peu sans
issues c'est-à-dire que si on teste
l'option de la dissolution évidemment on
peut pas s'empêcher de faire des
intentions de vote on prend avec
prudence mais attention de vote elle
nous disent quelque chose de très clair
c'est que la majorité sera encore moins
importante pour Emmanuel Macron au s'il
devait dissoudre il voire même il
pourrait ne pas l'avoir du tout si on
prend la question du changement de
Premier ministre oui on a
potentiellement une impulsion qui serait
différente mais est-ce que ça élargit la
majorité au sein de l'assemblée a priori
non en tout cas pas dans les dans
l'équilibre actuel des forces est-ce que
ça remobilise son camp qui aurait perdu
confiance dans la première ministre
alors qu'ils sont toujours derrière le
président de la République pas vraiment
Isabelle borne elle a pas un problème au
sein des des sympathisants Renaissance
il la critique pas plus que ça elle fait
le job pour eux le problème c'est
qu'elle élargit pas elle va pas chercher
ailleurs et ça pour le coup c'est pas
quelque chose qui pourrait être résolu
donc les options sur la table sont quand
même très très limitées là ce qui fait
pour l'instant c'est un petit peu
contrôle en bon français c'est à dire
qu'il va parler à sa cible en lui disant
il le dites sur toute la fin de
l'intervention je suis le président que
vous connaissez c'est ça toute la fin
l'intervention Notre-Dame c'est je vous
l'avais dit je l'ai fait donc vous
pouvez me l'avons fait d'ailleurs oui
nous l'avons fait c'est nous il y a le
jeu pour donner l'impulsion et le nous
pour réussir à tenir les défis des
quatre ou cinq ans il le dit aussi quand
il parle du covid d'ailleurs c'était un
moment on était tous ensemble tous
réunis j'ai mis la France au centre de
les intérêts et je vous ai quelque part
pris sur mon dos et on est tous partis
retrouver l'esprit de responsabilité de
la période covid absolument et toute
cette partie là du discours c'est ça
c'est faisons bloc déjà entre nous parce
que la capacité d'élargir que soit dans
l'opinion avec ces trois grands pôles
qui quand même désormais sont assez
stables dans toutes nos enquêtes ou à
l'Assemblée où on voit très bien que la
possibilité d'élargir les majorités et
peu probable en tout cas à ce stade ça
bloque un peu alors justement ça bloque
un peu pour débloquer Emmanuel Macron se
retrouve
certains y verront une ironie obligé
d'ouvrir la porte et de et de de
s'appuyer sur les corps intermédiaires
et notamment les syndicats
l'intersyndical particulièrement unie
depuis trois mois je vous propose deux
réactions tout de suite d'abord celle de
Sophie Binet la secrétaire générale de
la CGT qui nous parle d'un Emmanuel
Macron sourd et désincarné
Sophie Binet ça doit être prêt vous
voyez c'est en régie il faut que le
magnéto c'était une expression de mon
époque il y a plus de Magnéto mais c'est
pas grave on va faire comme s'il y avait
un magnéto et que il était en train de
tourner et que donc le son de Sophie
Binet est prêt voilà question qu'on se
pose c'est sur quelle planète vit
Emmanuel Macron cette allocution aurait
pu être faite par tchat JPY il y avait
un côté très désincarné et on se demande
depuis trois mois dans quel pays il vit
parce qu'on a le sentiment qu'il n'a pas
entendu ce que lui ont dit est répété
les millions de manifestants et de
manifestants les millions de salariés
grévistes les toutes les organisations
syndicales qui lui ont dit cette réforme
est violente injustifiée et on peut
faire autrement puisque au début de son
allocution il a recommencé à expliquer
qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres solutions
que c'était indispensable etc chose
qu'on a expliqué sur tous les tons en
faisant des propositions alternatives
qui n'ont pas été examinées autre
réaction celle de Laurent Berger cette
fois-ci pour la CFDT un vide dans
l'intervention voilà ce qu'il me dit
il y a un espèce de vide dans
l'intervention du président de la
République il y a rien dedans qui est
une forme de considération à tous ces
travailleurs et travailleuses qui sont
touchés parce qu'ils vont devoir
travailler deux années de plus donc on
attendait autre chose évidemment et
quand on perspectives qui sont données
c'est un peu un discours de la méthode
pour une dixième fois mais rien de
concret
Florent a dit au ce qui est intéressant
dans les réactions de des leaders chefs
de fil de l'opposition des opposition de
gauche c'est que et c'est le vrai aussi
d'ailleurs le syndicat et c'est logique
c'est qu'il renvoie tous vers le 1er mai
là aujourd'hui on a l'impression que de
toute façon il y a une situation figée
qui peut rien se passer avant cette
démonstration de force du 1er mai mais
si on essaye de se projeter un peu après
un Laurent Berger il va finir par par
peut-être saisir l'opportunité d'une
négociation quand même
effectivement je pense qu'il n'a pas
d'autre choix parce que il y a une inter
syndicale mais ça n'empêche pas les
syndicats d'être rivaux néanmoins alors
certes les élections professionnelles ne
sont pas lointaines donc les échéances
viendront mais la CFDT elle a une base
extrêmement réformiste et donc sur la
durée en dehors de l'épisode de réforme
des retraites je pense que ça serait
compliqué de maintenir une position de
fermeture totale alors que des acquis
sociaux pourraient être arrachés et que
c'est d'ailleurs l'obligation désormais
du président de la République puisque
les républicains comme les syndicats
demandent des acquis sociaux alors pas
nécessairement les mêmes enfin dans tous
les cas il faudra qu'il y ait un bilan
social puisque tout le monde se rallie à
ce sujet là donc Laurent Berger il est
condamné et il le sait il est condamné à
retourner à la table des négociations il
a d'ailleurs dans les déclarations
récentes malgré un contexte de tension
il n'a pas du tout évacué le fait qu'il
retournerait à la table des négociations
ce qui n'est pas le cas de ces de ces
autres
partenaires de la
on va pas tirer des pensions à Gwen mais
imaginez que cette union syndicale très
solide jusqu'à présent va finir par se
fissurer un jour ou l'autre quoi dans la
stratégie pas forcément ça veut pas
forcément dire ça non je pense que il y
a un intérêt à ce que l'Inter syndical
poursuivre un combat symbolique
lancinant sur la réforme des retraites
et que à chaque fois qu'il y a une
négociation le préalable ça soit de
remettre sur le tapis la réforme des
traites parce que c'est un catalyseur et
que les syndicats en ont besoin ils
n'ont jamais été aussi utile que dans la
période qui vient de s'écouler donc ça
sera un peu leur moto que de dire que la
réforme des traites la réforme des
traîtres en revanche une fois que ce
préalable aura été acquis je pense que
pour la CFDT il y aura la volonté
décrocher des acquis sociaux et de
pouvoir valoriser son bilan de syndicats
réformiste ce qui n'est pas du tout
l'optique des deux autres syndicats qui
composent l'Inter syndicale donc je
crois que chacun jouera sa partition
tout en étant respectueux de cette
insert syndicale qui en termes de
capacité de mobilisation a clairement
mis les syndicats sur demande la scène
c'est et puis quand même sortir de cette
séquence mal au sens large j'englobe
dedans les futurs négociations en disant
voilà ce qu'on a obtenu pas simplement
pour les syndicats sortir sur un concept
malheureusement la réforme des retraites
elle a été votée pour humiliée et
finalement appliquée Émilie vouliez
intervenir on a l'impression je reviens
sur le mot parallèle c'est pas la
première fois que Sophie Binet utilise
ça de la CGT elle parlait de réalité
parallèle vivait le gouvernement et
c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression qu'il y
a deux mots interrompre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon irréel Macron complètement
hors de la réalité revient souvent mais
parce qu'ils ont même pas le même timing
pas le même temps du tout les syndicats
sont bloqués en effet sur le 1er mai et
sur cette réforme des retraites 64 ans
on l'entend quand même même si Laurent
Berger éventuellement serait prêt à
négocier on l'entend bloquer là-dessus
dans les propos que vous avez reporté là
alors qu'on a un Emmanuel Macron qui se
projette et qui insiste beaucoup sur
l'indépendance nationale puisque c'est
ce qu'il dit aussi à l'international sur
l'Europe cette vision beaucoup plus
globale en gros je porte ça contre vents
et marées et même contre vous tous parce
que c'est pour le bien de la Nation pour
un projet ce sont destin en fait c'est
de réhabiliter la France parmi les
puissances pour le bien-être des gens et
je pense qu'il est dans un monde comme
ça parallèle sur ça parallèle ou pas en
tout cas c'est son monde à l'heure
actuelle et on sent presque des des
accents de garage Schroeder de
sacrifices en fait pour des réformes qui
modifieraient tellement le pays qu'il
irait beaucoup mieux il y a vraiment
deux dialogues qui peuvent pas en tout
cas de partie qui peuvent pas pour
l'instant se parler tant que c'est pas
purger la réforme des retraites 100
jours mais déjà 15 jours de moins quoi
parce que puisqu'il faut attendre début
dans ce constat de réalité c'est sûr et
je rebondis c'est que ces deux réalités
parallèles c'est le terme est bon en
tout cas c'est aussi deux
positionnements qui sont très très
différents quand on compare
l'intervention d'aujourd'hui non pas
celle de dire un mois mais celle de 2018
de 10 décembre 2018 on est un mois après
le début des gilets jaunes et c'est le
moment Emmanuel Macron reprend la main
le l'intervention est complètement
différente là Emmanuel Macron il laisse
un espace parce qu'il va pas au contact
en 2018 lors d'intervention il fait
finalement sur ce format là il fait
premièrement à miracule pas très fort on
n'est pas allé assez vite et assez fort
sur les réformes c'est ma faute mais les
choses vont changer c'est des mesures
concrètes qu'on n'a pas eu ce soir parce
que il nous a envoyé le premier ministre
c'est les 100 euros pour les personnes
qui sont au SMIC à l'époque et puis
c'est le grand débat national où il dit
moi je vais me déplacer et je vais
rencontrer les gens ce qui est pas du
tout ce qu'on a vu là parce qu'il a se
positionnement effectivement un peu en
surplomb du président de la République
qui disent j'ai une vision je
fixe le cap on utilise l'expression en
permanence ces temps-ci et le reste du
gouvernement ensuite mènera les réformes
en faisant ça il montre il est en
surplomb et qu'il a une vision à long
terme en revanche il laisse le champ
libre à son gouvernement c'est sûrement
très bien mais aussi aux oppositions
alors je rappelle qu'il il y a trois
grands chantiers qui sont qui ont été
lancés par le Président de la République
le chantier du travail avec le nouveau
pacte de la vie au travail le chantier
de la justice et de l'ordre républicain
et on va écouter l'extrait d'Emmanuel
Macron sur ce thème dans un cours
instant et puis il y a le chantier des
services publics que le Président de la
République
décrit en disant le progrès pour mieux
vivre ou là il lance il rappelle ce qui
a déjà été fait à la fois dans les
collection nationale et la santé en
annonçant de futures mesures on va faire
un focus ensemble si vous voulez bien
sûr cette question de justice et ordre
républicain parce que c'est intéressant
sur le clin d'oeil aux parties on écoute
Emmanuel Macron sur ce thème
deuxième chantier et celui de la justice
et de l'ordre républicain et
démocratique
l'État de droit et notre socle et il n'y
a pas de liberté sans loi ni sans
sanction envers ceux qui transgresse le
droit des autres dans ce but nous
continuerons à recruter plus de 10 000
magistrats et agents continueront
d'améliorer le fonctionnement de notre
justice et nous sommes en train de créer
200 brigades de gendarmerie dans nos
campagnes
alors on avait sur ce plateau dans la
première partie de l'émission le
sénateur LR Stéphane lauretulier qui qui
disait finalement j'ai eu un discours de
droite quoi il était aussi cash que que
ça je vais vous poser la même question à
tous les deux je commence avec vous
pierre Adrien Bartoli et est-ce que
c'était un discours de droite ou en tout
cas est-ce que le CLIN d'œil était très
très marqué vis-à-vis de de LR oui très
appuyé enfin pour le coup les choses
sont très claires auprès des LR auprès
de sa base aussi il faut pas oublier que
la base Macron elle a changé si on est
plus en 2017 avec deux tiers des
lecteurs de gauche c'est plus ça
l'électorat d'Emmanuel Macron mais oui
c'était un clin d'oeiler hésitez pas le
seul d'ailleurs parce que toute la
partie finale sur de retour du
Libéralisme après le quoi qu'il en coûte
toute la partie 7 bureaucratie trop
importante qu'il faut arriver à dépasser
c'est un peu la même chose c'est un
appel du pied c'est montrer qu'on arrive
à parler la même langue qu'on a
potentiellement les mêmes valeurs et
pourquoi pas construire quelque chose
ensemble demain Pascal Perino est-ce que
le on en parle depuis des mois et vous
êtes venus sur ce plateau plusieurs fois
et c'était passionnant mais cette
hypothèse d'un accord de gouvernement ou
d'une coalition avec LR ça va être le
serpent de mer de ce second quinquennat
ou alors ça peut aboutir ça va être le
serpent de mer parce que ça a des
raisons objectives d'être le serpent
parce que ou bien le président de la
République arrive à reprendre
l'initiative et à construire ce qu'on
appelait jadis des majorités d'idées
projets par projet avec la première
ministre voilà qui qui arrive à faire ce
qu'elle n'a pas réussi à faire sur les
retraites ou bien
se posera bien si l'on veut stabiliser
les choses pour quatre ans parce que
c'est pas un long qui reste c'est 4 ans
se posera bien à un moment la
possibilité d'un véritable accord de
gouvernement basé sur un compromis comme
le font mais j'allais dire toutes les
grandes démocraties parlementaires
simplement nous sommes nous dans une
démocratie à forte dimension
présidentielle qui rend les choses plus
compliquées mais avant d'en arriver là
vous voyez qu'il a envoyé dans son
message et dans les trois chantiers
j'allais dire il y en a un peu pour tout
le monde si on veut si on veut
caricaturer l'ordre pour la droite le
travail pour la gauche et voilà les
progrès des services publics pour tous
quoi voilà
et voilà on voit bien que le président
cherche au plan électoral a continué à
s'adresser d'ailleurs il en a parlé à un
moment de son patrimoine de sa
spécificité qui cherche à dépasser le
clivage gauche-droite donc il reste
toujours dans cette idée parce que il se
rend bien compte quand il appelle à la
fin à l'apaisement et à l'unité qu'il
faut bien que ce pays pour fonctionner
est une unité alors là il cherche un peu
une unité à la base en disant cherchant
à retrouver du moins dans ces 100 jours
un peu d'apaisement à l'unité mais il y
a toujours une relation entre le sommet
la base et un jour faudra se poser le
problème d'une unité partielle relative
au sommet sinon je ne vois pas très bien
comment ça va fonctionner pendant 4 ans
on a l'impression que c'est quand même
un peu un échec du en même temps parce
que là finalement s'il y a une coalition
avec les LR c'est une espèce de Nouvelle
Droite finalement c'est c'est perdant
perdant c'est à dire que LR se
retrouveraient complètement fondu dans
ce en même temps qui deviendrait quelque
part la Nouvelle Droite donc on voit
qu'il y a une limite à ce projet de 2017
qui était beau sur le papier pragmatique
d'aller chercher à droite et à gauche ce
qu'il y a de bien mais qui globalement
sur la pratique n'a pas l'air de bien
fonctionner puisque là on voit un
Emmanuel Macron qui est quand même très
isolé que ça soit on en a parlé sur les
syndicats mais aussi sur les forces
politiques et qui avance comme vous
l'avez dit avec de plus en plus
d'autorité parce que si on parle du
régalien on a quand même une
manifestation de l'autorité de plus en
plus forte il y a un élément alors c'est
dans le même chapitre sur justice ordre
républicain on va dire dont on a
finalement peu parlé en tout cas pas
encore avec vous mais pas non plus dans
le dans le premier mais là c'est sur le
nos institutions il ouvre la porte en
disant enfin voilà rendez-vous avec la
présence de la doucement vous dites
de l'Assemblée nationale et avec le
président du Sénat pour revoir le
fonctionnement de nos institutions alors
je vous vois goguenar un petit peu ou
dubitatif non mais ça fait partie
effectivement d'un running gag qu'on
connaît chez Emmanuel Macron depuis
qu'il est élu puisque la première
réunion du Parlement en congrès c'était
sur la réforme des institutions avec
exactement les mêmes anciennes qui
reviennent c'est à dire le temps de la
démocratie on doit aller plus vite avec
plus de démocratie donc c'est
franchement on reprend le discours de je
crois juillet 2018 et on regarde cela
c'est la même chose entre-temps il y a
quand même eu quand même deux
avortements constitutionnels
c'est-à-dire la première tentative de
réforme a échouer et la deuxième
tentative vous voulez il a essayé de
revenir vers Gérard Larcher à tout
autant échoué donc je recherche à
comprendre en réalité au-delà des
gadgets grâce aux ces œufs qui se
retrouvent une seconde jeunesse ou je
n'ai pas cité mais il a lui cité le
président et en réalité il n'a plus que
ça parce que c'est bien parce que la
bénévolence du CESU qui trouve un
intérêt qui n'a jamais trouvé sous la 5e
République en fait le Conseil économique
et donc le CESU qui ne savait pas à quoi
il servait sert finalement de béquilles
à Emmanuel Macron parce que c'est la
seule réforme des institutions qui ne
coûte rien qui ne demande pas de réforme
légitive et qui repose en fait sur des
moyens existants donc je pense je fais
un pari j'ai toujours risqué de faire
des paris qu'on va avoir des conventions
à n'en plus finir orchestré par le CESU
parce que tout autre réforme
institutionnelle échouera sauf s'il
essaie à travers l'inscription de l'IVG
dans la Constitution d'avoir un vecteur
sur lequel il y aurait une négociation
mais Gérard Larcher bien plus madré que
lui là dessus et il n'a aucun intérêt à
le voir à progresser là-dessus alors il
y a un autre outil entre guillemets en
tout cas créé par Emmanuel Macron c'est
le conseil international de la
refondation on écoute là-dessus
celui-ci toutes les forces d'action et
de bonne volonté nos mères nos élus nos
forces politiques nos syndicats tous
ensemble je compte mieux les associer en
relançant dès le mois de mai des
coalitions et alliance nouvelle sur les
bases solides du conseil et national de
la refondation au plus près du terrain
et chacun d'entre vous avait un rôle à
jouer il nous faut moins de loi moins de
bureaucratie plus de liberté d'actions
d'expérimentation de pouvoir
d'initiative à l'échelle de nos vies oui
c'est cet élan national auquel je crois
le Conseil national de la refondation le
l'adjectif solide et peut-être pas celui
qui nous serait venu spontanément à
l'esprit parce qu'elle Perino en effet
étant donné le Conseil national de leur
effondation le CNR des comptes
d'ailleurs utile
ces trois lettres c'était vraiment
audacieux trop audacieux
et il n'a aucune existence ce conseil
national de la refondation donc là le
président sort de la naphtaline cette
idée du Conseil national de la
refondation qui au départ avait un
objectif tout à fait autre c'était de
montrer une fois de plus aux
institutions représentatives classiques
que voilà elle jouait un rôle mais
qu'elle pouvait être challenge et
comment on dit aujourd'hui par ce fameux
Conseil national de la refondation alors
là comme on dit dans le discours de la
grande distribution il positive ce
conseil national de la de la refondation
et il relance ça pour habiller au fond
sans quoi il n'a jamais cru jusqu'à
maintenant c'est à dire l'organisation
des forces vives on dit des corps
intermédiaires de la Nation pour aller
plus loin sur des dossiers politiques
mais y croit-il vraiment oui
là il utilise le levier des mers quand
même on peut dire de manière très
communicationnelle parce que c'est une
grande opération de communication
mais vraiment les forces vivent les
syndicats les parties les grandes
associations pour le dire vulgairement
c'est vraiment pas son truc alors et ça
ça repose la question de la verticalité
du du pouvoir regarder ce sondage sur le
le côté autoritaire d'Emmanuel Macron
61% des Français qui pensent que il est
plus autoritaire que en 2017 dans les
traits de caractère que les Français
prête de spontanément ou prioritairement
Emmanuel Macron est-ce que celui-là
l'autoritaire ou l'autoritarisme ou
l'autorité si on essaye d'être un peu
plus positif bien souvent c'est le
principal c'est le premier c'est celui
qui arrive en tête en même temps c'est
la fonction qui veut ça non d'une
certaine façon oui sauf que quand on
l'applique Emmanuel Macron on est pas
sûr de ce qu'on mesure réellement c'est
à dire qu'est-ce qu'on mesure une forme
d'autorité d'un responsable politique
qui dirige le pays et en qui on a
confiance ou est-ce qu'on mesure
un traits de caractère ou une tendance à
brusquer un petit peu ses interlocuteurs
ce qui est plutôt une critique et on
regarde l'étude d'opinion récente on
pense plutôt de ce côté là désormais il
y a un deuxième aspect qui va avec ça
c'est que cette autorité c'est
effectivement une verticalité mais c'est
une verticalité qui n'est pas simplement
une position de surplomb parce qu'il
peut voir loin et anticiper ce qui
arrive c'est une position où il est
coupé de sa base et la première critique
qui est faite Emmanuel Macron c'est
justement ça c'est de ne pas comprendre
ce que vivent les Français on l'a vécu
tout au de la séquence tout au long de
la séquence des retraites on nous a dit
que on avait un exécutif a commencé par
le Président de la République qui
imposait une réforme sur quelque chose
qui ne connaissait pas parce qu'il ne
connaît pas les français d'après ce que
les études qu'on fait évidemment et donc
du coup ils ne peuvent pas comprendre ce
que signifie pour les petites gens de
travailler deux ans de plus et ça le
fond du discours qui a été portrait et
c'est le trait d'image qui a le plus
pati de la séquence pour Emmanuel Macron
c'était d'ailleurs déjà son point faible
mais désormais on est moins d'un
Français sur 5 qui considère qui
comprend les Français quand on est
président de la République ça peut être
un problème oui justement je me disais
qu'il y a pas beaucoup parlé de l'effet
de l'inflation d'ailleurs il en a parlé
un tout petit peu sur les l'augmentation
des revenus mais c'est quand même le
cœur des préoccupations à l'heure
actuelle des Français et des Françaises
et c'est vrai qu'il a fait complètement
abstraction et ça c'est un signal de
dire je suis pas dans les dans les
préoccupations concrètes des uns et des
autres c'est compliqué merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce sens
public
spécial allocution du Président de la
République je vous dis à demain 18h pour
un nouveau numéro de cette émission et
puis votre prochain rendez-vous avec la
politique ce sera dans la matinale
Clémentine Autain député la France
insoumise qui sera l'invité Dorian
Mancini sera 8 heures du matin belle
soirée
[Musique]